around the world governments are
scrambling to offer what Aid they can
with teams of rescue Specialists already
arriving in Turkey but also hit was
neighboring Syria where the pitch is far
more complicated already devastated by a
civil war getting relief where it's
needed will prove the biggest challenge
a warning that our Middle East
correspondent Aleister bunkel's report
includes pictures of one young victim
being treated for his wounds
Syria has suffered more than a decade of
Civil War and is completely unprepared
to deal with something like this
many of the buildings were already
heavily damaged in the conflict or
poorly built they would have stood no
chance in an earthquake this strong
people rushed outside into the dark
early morning frightened and with
nothing but the clothes they wore on
their back
uh
Allah
foreign
in rebel-held areas the Syrian Civil
Defense better known as the white
helmets were on the ground immediately
they're used to dealing with the
aftermath of airstrikes but this has
left them overwhelmed
uh
um
foreign
Rescuers worked with their bare hands to
pull survivors from the rubble
a small girl was saved limb but alive
[Music]
they were rushed to hospitals already
struggling under the weight of War
our colleague in Northwest Syria filmed
these pictures of the Wounded being
treated a child cries with pain as
Medics Stitch a wound in his head
Syria
urgently needs International help but
getting Aid into rebel-held areas will
be a huge challenge in itself
we are ready to provide support to the
people there we are looking at all the
needs wherever they are that we do not
look at the politics and we would like
to see the politics put aside and
facilitate the access of the U.N and
human tagging Partners here
from Aleppo to access those people who
need help
some streets have been totally flattened
Rescuers on their hands and knees shout
through small gaps to see if anyone is
alive
cranes are being used to pull heavy
blocks of concrete from the top of piles
that were once homes
millions of syrians are already refugees
from the years of fighting communication
lines were already patchy and there are
few International organizations
operating on the ground there the full
Grim story of what has happened in
Northwest Syria is yet to be revealed
Aleister bunker Sky News